the town of India in northern India
sprawls on the banks of the river Ganges
here stands one of the most important
temples in India it's the main temple of
the Vindhya vicinity a powerful Hindu
goddess thousands throng to this shrine
but this is more than a house of worship
within the bustling temple down a dim
corridor is a tiny locked room out of
bounds to all but a tormented few it's
called the cave of spirits a home for
the dead and last hope for the possessed
in the holy waters of the Ganges a man
and his helpers prepare for an arduous
task
Lakshmi kam Shukla is an exorcist a
pursuer of spirits and today he'll take
on some formidable foes families have
traveled many miles from all over
northern India to seek his help I have
four five lumps in my neck I get dizzy
sometimes my eyes roll up my neck turned
stiff but their woes appear to begin in
strikingly similar ways usually at
Twilight women walking down lonely roads
sends an eerie presence they feel
themselves under attack
overnight something takes possession of
them some blame gods of the earth and
air others point to spirits of the dead
no one is certain
well a lot of people here do say that
this is just superstitious those who
don't face this problem say it's
nonsense
those who suffer believe it's real Sally
kromm came with his 15 year old daughter
Moony for eight months Mooney has been
depressed and acting strangely
she had a stomach ache India her eyes
got blood-red she starts talking
nonsense
whatever comes into her head Sally kromm
and his wife of try doctors now as a
last resort they'll attempt exorcism
for Mooney and the other girls the
moment is at hand The Exorcist works
them into a trance one by one the girls
break down yep it on when the spirit
comes forth that a girl loses all
control over her body but well that's
what I know she has been possessed The
Exorcist urges the spirit to talk it
seems ready to surrender I will leave
her body you can we'll leave her forever
yeah the spirit has agreed to leave but
the Exorcist must find it another home
he knows of only one place a place where
he can jail it for eternity the cave of
spirits but first he has to get Mooney
and the other young women and their
demons to the cave the dancing distracts
the spirits keeping them from bolting
the chamber doors are carefully opened
the spirit that possesses muni responds
with a spasm of rage then leaves the
girl's body the Smashing of a coconut
signals the rituals end Muni will leave
but the spirit that tormented her will
remain here forever two days later the
Exorcist makes a house call to check on
Muni for this family The Exorcist
extreme treatment seems to have worked
and they now count themselves believers
in the world of spirits